Hello?
I'm so confused.
Hold on a second, please. Professional stream going
on here.
You
know, during the intro, I heard my intro
music playing over the top of itself and
it was very much confusing myself to the
point where I muted it because I was
concerned that it was playing twice.
I then proceeded to ask my guest if
he had the YouTube page open and I
guess what?
It was me. So I was listening to
my intro video while trying to talk to
you and introduce the show and now I
feel like an absolute ass. However,
we're gonna get things kicked off today because
things go wrong all the time and it's
usually my fault as I always always say
on the stream.
So today oh, hello. Welcome back to the
Rawkode Academy. My name is David Flanagan.
You will know me as Rawkode. And today
we are taking a look at Kubescape. It
is a Kubernetes open source tool providing multi
cloud Kubernetes
single pane of glass.
As we see in the title graphic, we're
going to show you how to secure your
clusters like the NSA.
Now,
as you can tell by my mistakes in
the first minus thirty seconds of the show,
I am not smart enough to guide us
through this today. However, we are joined by
someone who is. So let me please introduce
our guest, Ben from Armelsec.
Hey, man. How's it going?
Hi. Hi, David. Thanks for having me. See,
you must be feeling very confident now that
I've made all the mistakes in the first
ten seconds. Right? That takes the pressure off.
Yeah.
Well, that's just just the beginning of the
show. You will see my mistakes in a
few minutes.
Alright. Awesome. Well, thank you so much for
joining us today. And for anyone who's not
familiar with you, doesn't follow you on Twitter,
can you share a little bit of information
about Ben?
So yeah. Okay. I will try to keep
it short. Okay. So
I'm a
cybersecurity veteran, okay, coming into the cloud native
space,
like, few for a few years now.
Mostly, you know, we're working in ARMOR,
which is a startup
we've
founded two years ago.
We're working on Kubernetes security
and improving
the security
of applications in Kubernetes.
And what I can I can tell you
by myself that I'm the VP engineering here?
But, you know, as a small startup, you
most of the things you are doing, you're
you're doing everything.
So you're also washing the dishes at the
office and
everything. So I'm a father of beyond the
time, I'm a father of four,
and I love to play chess.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing all that with
us.
I always like to ask a question where
we have security focused people on, and it's
is Kubernetes secure by default?
What's your opinions on that?
So,
actually, this is really good question. Okay? I
know that you're you've asked someone else, but,
you know, this is something always first of
all, I'm a fan. Okay? So
of your show. And and Kubernetes,
I have to tell tell you that one
of the most interesting things about Kubernetes that
Kubernetes
really gave the people behind Kubernetes gave a
real thought of security.
Okay?
And and this not this this doesn't mean
that that Kubernetes is secured by itself, okay,
because there is nothing which is secured by
itself today.
But but I really do think that many
things, okay, for many years, okay, which, you
know, we've been laughing at different
technologies.
Okay. Web servers, CGI bins, if you remember,
and stuff like that. Okay. That's how funny
was that how they didn't thought of security
from the beginning or not just from the
beginning, in the middle either.
But but in Kubernetes, they really gave it
serious thought and many things are in there.
This doesn't mean that everything is fine,
but this is really good. I mean, it's
it's really great to work with Kubernetes because
you feel that really the thought is there
and and the good start is there.
Yeah. Definitely. 100%.
I think, you know, when people talk to
me, they're making typically, they're migrating to Kubernetes,
and they're doing that with security is one
of those tenants that they really hope to
get because, hey, it's it's in a container.
Right? Like, what bad things can happen And
I schedule everything in containers. But as with
all tools, every tool in the world is
that it's easy to go down a path
of misconfiguration and breaking stuff, or even just
done right ignoring best practices and going into
the security context and going wild on it,
right? Like, it all comes down to individual
users. And
I think that's why I'm really excited to
kind of introduce people to Kubescape today because
it's going to bring a lot of these
misconfigurations and bad practices front and center and
show people like,
maybe you need to look at why you're
doing this and maybe there's a better way
to it. So can you I've said Kubescape,
like, three times now, so we might as
well tell people what it is. Could you
give us the the description of what is
Kubescape, please?
So Kubescape
is our open source project. Okay? We've
we started, like, in the last summer,
which is
a tool scanning your cluster
against misconfigurations
at the beginning. And and
not just saying in the beginning, okay, because
we have a long way to go and
we have many exciting things going on.
But the really, really basic is checking your
cluster and checking your YAML files and Helm
charts before deployment,
checking them against
the best practices security best practices. And we've
you mentioned NSA and and really NSA was
was
a really good starting point for us. Okay?
Because,
you know, NSA CISA
framework
was released somewhere in August, I think,
where actually, you know, NSA,
you know, created this great document. Okay? It's
telling people what is the what can be
the problems with with the Kubernetes misconfigurations
and and, you know,
we created a a standard, okay, practical standard.
And and I'm telling practical because
because
many of you might know that there are
many other p standards like PCI,
SOC two, and stuff like that, are giving
you very, very high level, you know, ideas,
okay, of what should be the goal, but
doesn't give, you know for us engineers,
they they don't really give,
you know,
explicit, you know, instructions what to actually do
with it. And NSA, I think they took
this to the next level because they actually
told you things like,
guys,
okay,
encrypt
your etcd,
okay, which is, you know, it's something that
the engineer can do with it. Okay? So
and and we created
Kubescape around this framework.
And, literally, we sold, you know, the very
very big early success came with it, and
we added more more frameworks around the cubescape
ever since.
And and it's really we got
I cannot, you know, emphasis it enough. We
got a huge love back,
okay, from the from the community.
And
and we really got awesome feedback, okay, on
on how people are using this tool and
how they it helps them to find their
security issues
even, you know, before, but also within the
cluster,
and how this can the this improves their
security posture.
Awesome.
Yeah.
I I I can understand
why there's a lot of love for Kubescape.
Haven't been playing with it and poking at
it over the last kinda couple of weeks.
Like, I'm really excited to dive into it
more and and share that with everybody. So
yeah. Definitely.
We do have our first question from Mozz.
So, if you are watching us live, we
do encourage questions. Please get them into the
chat, we'll do our best to answer them.
Mozz, your question is very generic and I'll
give Ben the opportunity to answer it. But
if you want to, you know, follow-up with
maybe a few more specifics about what your
friends are struggling with, that would be great.
But most does ask, many of my cybersecurity
friends are struggling to adopt Kubernetes and cloud
native. Do you have any advice for them?
Wow. That that is great. I waved net
there. But Yeah. Yeah.
So I
I think I understand
where most is coming from, and and this
has been, I think, that that many
of us see. Okay? And it it's it's
really coming from
the, you know, the big not just pressure,
but but the big scape of of, you
know, landscape of of things today's cybersecurity
persona needs to look into
today. And, really, you know, once we had,
you know,
VMs and blades and, you know, we know
knew how to set up a firewall and
stuff like that, and and
and these systems are still living. Okay? And
and security person needs to really go into
take more on himself and learn other things
like cloud native not cloud. Okay. Not just
cloud native, but cloud cloud native, and then
Kubernetes.
And
and and I think that that really
there is no easy
solution. Okay? I think that the most of
cyber most cybersecurity
friends,
I'm pretty sure that we are great professionals,
and and they have all the basics. And
simply they have to take a few
you know, take their time and learn it.
Okay? And and
this I think that especially Kubernetes and cloud
native,
they they have a wonderful community
with
with really people who are ready to answer
questions
and and many, many
places where you have resources and, you know,
you cannot cheat it. You have to dive
in
Yeah. To death. Yeah. That's I think that's
probably one of the most important things, I
think. Like, when you're talking about,
you know, most of them, they're struggling with
this. Right? I mean, the wrong answer is
to go on your own and try and
do something bespoke because you think it's safer
and secure. Like, herd mentality here is really
important. We have so many active organizations
and people promoting best practices in the cloud
data space that you want to go on
with them and standing on the shoulders of
everyone else that's doing the hard work upfront.
And I think we're in a really exciting
time now in the cloud data space where
there has been a big push on security.
You know, we've got Armorsec pushing Kubescape, we've
got chain guard doing all the image signing
stuff with cosign. Like, we're never been in
such a fortunate position. I mean, you think
back to Kubernetes in 2037,
'20 '18, like, wow, that was that was
scary.
Where we are now, I think people should
be excited, hopefully. I I I feel that
should
be excited.
Yeah. It's completely and and and I think
and really, you know, just just there there
is something okay, I want to mention something
that came into my mind just, you know,
after my answer. That
yeah. But but because because if you take
if you, you know,
think about, you know, all the progress we
made, okay, in the in the last, you
know,
five to ten years. Okay? And the call
then the whole adoption of infrastructure as a
code. Okay?
I think that that there is
really a new mindset, okay, for security personals.
Okay? They have to adopt. Okay? Because,
you know, the secrets in Kubernetes are not
coming from, you know, I don't know, from
just from the air. Okay? They are coming
from a Git repo. They are coming from
from
a script, okay, which is,
you know, which is stored in some some
kind of a bucket. Okay? Either it's the
kit or or or something else. And
and and this is not the time where
where we went through with our USB, you
know, drives and and started to distribute keys
in the blades.
So,
yeah, this is also a change of mindset,
not just, you know, technicality.
Yeah. 100%.
I sometimes look back at some of the
things I used to do to distribute keys
and secrets and I'm just absolutely ashamed.
Yeah.
Alright. Thank you.
So thank you for that question, boss.
Hopefully, that helps. If you have anything more
specific, please drop it into the chat.
And we have a hey from Joshua. Hey,
Joshua. Thank you for joining us.
Alright. Ben, you're gonna guide us through a
look at Kubescape today. So if you can
get your screen share ready, we'll pop over
there and then we'll show the audience how
cool this is. Okay.
Wait a second. I'm just
also, I need my technical
half minute here. Yeah. Take all the time
you need. No rush. Yeah.
So so
I don't know if you see my screen.
Let me pull that up now.
We can.
We see a terminal, and you're typing. Awesome.
So yeah, so we are in terminal. I
think this is the best place we can
be. Okay.
So I just wanted to, you know, really
to give you an intro for those who
care about cubescape
who haven't heard or or you're newbies
for us. So, again, you can find us
in GitHub or most of cubescape.
You can see here our project.
Now
within Project OKA, as I told you, the
simplest, you know, to start with Kubescape is
is simply installing our CLI tool. So our
CLI Kubescape is, like, is, by default, package
is a CLI tool. And what it does
is
it scans your either your your your cluster
or your YAML files or Helm charts and
looks for security issues within. So
we talked about before that that
that we came from the world of what
we of NSA.
So what I meant by this is that
we call we are organizing our what we
call controls,
which are some something like tests.
We are organizing them into frameworks. Okay? So
think about it as groups. Okay? And and
we have this NSA framework
containing
multiple tests or controls as well.
But we have other different frameworks
like we have the Microsoft Mitra framework
which is another
another
approach, okay, other set of of tests
which was prepared from this every security research
team of Microsoft
and
and other sets
which I will show you later.
And what you can do is simply, you
know, download Kubescape with a single liner here.
You can copy paste just as you saw
it before
and
and, you know, install it. So right now,
okay, we have more than
one kind of of application packaging of Kubescape.
One is what you saw right now, the
CLI tool. And later, I will if we'll
have time,
I will show also that we can install
it as a cluster component.
But the simplest thing, okay, you can do
with Kubescape is simply write cubescape
scan.
Okay. And then what cubescape does is it
connects
the cube API from the current context, which
is configured,
and simply looks into your your configurations,
your Kubernetes object,
and and test them against different tests. So
in this case, okay, if you this is
what it took
to run the whole test. It was it
was, you know you can see that it
was less than a minute.
And you can see a list of of
different tests we've ran
here,
which we again, what we call test is
in our language is called controls.
And for example okay. I can bring
for example, here one test called container host
port.
So I'm telling you right now that container
host port is
a a control which checks whether,
the host port was defined
for
for a given deployment
or workload.
And you can see that there is a
single resource which failed this,
this best practice
out of
19.
And based on these results, okay, we are
we are
computing,
you know, an aggregated risk score
of your cluster, which in my case, I
just installed
a Minikube here with with
with the Hipster shop application
where I developed and made some, you know,
security
big no nos
order to be able to show you some
of the good things. But just going back
to the what is the output of the
CLI is
so, for example, there is another control called,
writable host pass mount. Okay? So it means
that it is a it is really bad
practice from a security perspective to to mount
host pass and and and also not just
to mount host, but even
to enable writing to that host path.
So in this case,
we found, you know,
four workloads.
Like, we found Kubescape proxy uses
host pass now. Okay. We see that ETC
is using it, Kubescape controller manager, and storage
provisioner. So it's it's
you're asking yourself, like, That's a little bit
strange. Okay? Because these are these are Kubernetes
components.
Okay? And why I'm complaining why Kubescape is
complaining about Kubernetes components.
And it's a it this is a, you
know, this is an approach we took at
the beginning. Okay? Because,
you know, sometimes in security,
okay, I think best
approach is not to hide things, okay, even
though they are related to the system you're
working in. So in the in our case,
really, the Kubescape proxy
requires a host path to be, mounted. Okay?
Otherwise,
in Minikube,
it will work.
Okay? But on the other hand, the control
needs to list it, okay, because still this
is this can be in some
in some context, they this can become an
attack vector. Okay? A theoretical attack vector. Therefore,
we are listing it. The the we'll talk
about a little bit later what we are
going to do with it. Okay? Because in
Kubescape, it's very important for not just to
show you, you know, to drive results,
but also to to help you to work
with them and work your solve your issues.
So we'll get back to it, but I'm
looking here back to
other
other controls, other tests we've we've run here.
I want to bring you, you know, something
more interesting. Look. So we have this control
called
privileged container, okay, which is one of the
most basic checks, you know, in the
I think some of you already smiling,
I feel,
here because this is one of the most
basic tests, okay, on any security posture tool,
okay, checking whether you have privileged containers or
not in your environment.
So in this case, you can see that
that, there is a deployment in the Hipster
Shop namespace
called recommendation service,
which, again, for for the sake of, you
know, demonstrating the capabilities, okay, I've made it
to
a privileged container.
Any questions? Just
Yeah. David, do you want to answer? Yeah.
Yeah. We have one question on the chat,
but I'm gonna be selfish and ask my
own question first.
If you just go back down to your
table, you listed you present a bunch of
risk percentage scores, and I was curious if
you could help us interpret those.
Sorry? About what? So it says, like, we
have a risk score on the table of
a % skipped 94,
and does I don't know if those correlate
to the framework risks, which seem to be
in yellow above it. So so
yeah. Okay.
Yeah. So
very good question. So we have
and we have a a very differentiated risk
score calculation. Okay? So we what you see
here, the risk score here means, actually, you
know, the the the percent of of failed
resources on a given
test. Okay? So in this case, you have
you see that access container service account. Okay.
This means that the the container has access
to the service account token.
Out of 41 workloads, 41 of them has
access to the service account token. Okay? This
means that %
have failed. Okay?
Yeah. But for, for example, let's take something
with zero
and interesting
enough
here.
I think that in this case, the access
Kubernetes dashboard is not really interesting
from our point of view because we don't
have Kubernetes dashboard.
But, for example, both in default namespaces.
Great. So in general, okay, this is
best practice not to put pods in the
default namespace.
And as, you know, as of all the
pods in my cluster, okay, none of them
are
in the default
names. Therefore, there is a risk of zero
here.
And the correlation,
okay, with this framework risk, okay, which you
can see that you can see here, I
have
third 34
dot 97%
risk score of NSA.
So it's a little bit more complex. It's
not just a simple percent, Jeff, of the
calculation. Okay? Because
I would be happy, by the way, to
point you to documentation,
but we don't have it here about this
calculation method. But I will try to explain
you and
prevent you from going into the code and
reading it yourself. But the idea is is
as following. Okay? So
we are trying to calculate risk. Okay?
Accumulative
aggregated risk for the whole, for framework, for
whole cluster
based on what is the first potential outcome.
Okay? So, for example,
if you have, like, control a and b
and and you have five resources for each,
so we are creating
a a hundred a score of % in
case that every every resource
on every,
every of these controls
is, is failing
potentially.
Okay? And also adding,
you know, adding to the,
to the equation also the level of the
given control, how the severity of of the
given control. So, for example, privileged container has,
relatively high,
risk,
okay, and high, severity.
On the other hand, I don't know
let's take okay. Cluster return networking has a
medium
severity.
So we are adding to the to the
calculation all these,
you know, things and and creating this cumulative
score.
Okay? And, again, we are taking the worst
case based on your cluster
if all the controls are failing on all
the resources,
the the and this is the worst case
scenario.
So
related to this, where are you on this
scale?
And,
yeah, I hope
I hope I could explain it.
Yeah. That definitely helps. Thank you very much.
Alright. Joshua's question from the chat.
Joshua asked, is Kubescape able to run on
managed Kubernetes solutions like EKS and GKE? Because
some other security tools won't or are not
able to run
since there's no,
I guess, unrestricted access to the control plane.
Yep. So
definitely.
So the answer is yes.
Kubescape as a CLI tool
is running today.
We we did some,
you know, statistics on how many people are
running, and we are seeing
some of the something like
30 to 40,000
run Kubescapes runs a week.
And
and and major
most
of those clusters are are managed Kubernetes clusters.
So they're like,
as it's all just said, EKS, GKE,
AKS clusters and also OpenShift and and the
DigitalOcean
clusters.
Actually, Kubescape by default, it only uses the
Kube API and from any anywhere where you
have access to the Kube API. And and
right now, you know, I have in this
console, I have access to the Kube API,
and I have
I have the authentication
credentials to
if Kubescape can access the Kube API, it's
it's it can scan your cluster.
Awesome. Thank you.
Alright.
So go back to your demo.
Yeah. So
just, you know, I wanted to show you,
and I hope that I have it here.
Yeah.
So
I have this YAML file, okay, because which
is, you know, actually
I hope I have to w get here.
Yeah. So
so what I wanted to show you that
just as I scanned,
you know,
the cluster,
I can take my YAML file also. Okay?
Before I'm I'm deploying
before before
I'm deploying it to to the cluster,
I can also scan it to not just
the Kubescape API. So and it I think
it's it was a, you know, it was
a really important
decision for us, okay, from a way we've
designed this architecture,
okay, and the way we designed this whole
whole project
to be to give an answer, not just
actual deployment and monitoring
a a a part of the things, but
also what do you want to do beforehand,
how do you want to prevent things, okay,
going into your production.
And, you know, I just run the scan
on the YAML file, and you can see
that I got the same table. Okay? So
some of the controls are skipped because they
are they are simply not relevant. They don't
have inputs to those things because the YAML
files doesn't doesn't
contain relevant
Kubernetes object.
But, for example, I can already see, okay,
that, again,
that I have here a a component
of workload
which has host IPC
privileges.
Okay? And this means that one of the
workloads out of the 12 workloads which I
had this and in the CML file
is already failing here. Okay? So, for example,
if if I'm, you know for example, for
our production
our own production c
a c c d, k, we we already
use Kubescape in the delivery pipes
and already looking into the things before they
get to the production environment
and stopping pipes, okay, from delivering, you know,
problematic things like, in this case, this privileged
container. It is the very same privileged container
you saw before in the cluster itself.
So if you're thinking about, you know, a
a
a a
development process and not just, you know, want
to understand what you have right now in
your cluster,
okay, but you also want to add Kubescape
into your whole work process, okay, you can
use it. Okay. We've just this week, okay,
someone decided to write a GitHub action, okay,
based for Kubescape, and it's we'll we'll have
you know, hopefully, by next week, you'll have
a a published GitHub action also,
you know, facilitating this test. So you will
able to add Kubescape
even easier
to your pipes
and your workflows,
and you'll be able to prevent, you know,
security misconfigurations
even before.
I'm curious about
what,
you know, what a production pipeline might look
like here. So, you showed how Kubescape can
reach the API server and do it in
cluster stuff. We've also got the ability to
run it at, like, GitHub action context to
prevent things ever getting to the cluster.
I mean, should the GitHub action be able
to block and deploy?
Is that something that we would encourage for
certain
profiles or controls?
And the end cluster stuff, is that something
that we should be running
regularly?
Is it something we run
all the time or just daily? Like, what
would what would you suggest?
So
definitely
okay. So I'm, you know, today,
I'm here, you know, as
on the on one hand, you know, my
heart is going for the security and and
and cloud native
community and development. But on the other hand,
I also, you know, have I also VP
engineering of of of a company. Right? And
and and this means that I need to
monitor
our flows and understand, okay, how to make
them better, how to make our our our,
you know, our processes better.
And, you know, the the
the idea of shifting left, okay, stopping things,
stopping problems, catching problems,
you know, very, very early, you know, is
is is really important. Okay? And and and
we are really, really committed, not just, you
know,
you know, we are not just talking to
the top, we are trying to walk the
walk, you know. Right? So
we really
mean that we want to integrate and bring
this information
as early as we can.
And while I'm talking,
although this is relatively new machine,
I'm trying to show you the same thing
even to make it more even interesting
in
in Visual Studio Code.
So
so we also released
Kubescape Visual Studio extension.
And the reason for that,
again, I'm installing here, and this is live
demo, so please, guys,
please give me, you know, just Slack because
hope it will work because I haven't tried
it right now before.
So what we really try to see, okay,
to make sure that that that all these
things are, you know, are
will, you know, coming with you from the
very
point of time where you start to write
your YAML fry files. You, you know, you
wrote wrote your, you know, your your Helm
chart and stuff. Okay? And and
going into
the direction of of your, you know, dev
and and staging a production systems.
And and, you know what, just let's see,
okay, if it works.
Okay. So, hopefully, you can
yeah. The scanning is scanning is working, but
it should also show me
show up also
during
yeah. As you can see here Oh, nice.
Okay. So you can already see here that
I'm already catching these issues
right in your editor. So I mean, sorry.
Not I. Okay? We are catching your issues.
Sorry.
But but but, really, you know, the the
point is here, okay, that to answer your
question that, yeah,
there's no question, okay, that you need to
scan your your production systems and monitor that.
Okay?
And maybe, you know, when when we are,
as engineers, are are dealing with
security requirements from your our
chief security officer in in your organization
or or, you know, you simply need to
provide some input to your your compliance
preferred compliance
type, you know, you need to bring in
information. You need to scan your cluster. Okay?
Because this is actually what you've what you
have.
But but from a configuration perspective,
I do believe I do believe that most
very most of things that can that can
be caught before needs to be caught before.
Okay? Yep. It's real and I think it's
really, really important.
Also, from a security perspective,
so you will have security issues, okay, if
your clusters.
Second
is that, yeah, it is way harder, okay,
to find these issues,
you know, far from you as a developer
and find them in in the production system.
Okay? And you you the access to that,
and you start to scan until you understand
how it works
instead of, you know, seeing it within
your, you know, your your
development environment.
Yeah. I'm gonna follow-up with one thing there,
but I just wanna Avanash said hello in
the chat and then Avanash followed up with,
hey. I'm also the person working on the
GitHub action. So nice work, Avanash. Yeah.
Yeah.
This is the great guy I was talking
about.
What I I like what
what I really resonate with about what you
said there is that we cannot really frustrating
position in Kubernetes land. Right? Like, the Kubernetes
maintainers and contributors made this decision to deprecate
pod security policies.
The past that they pushed everybody down was,
well, you should be using
Kiverno or some other in cluster tools to
do mutate and admission and validate and admission
where you don't really know there's a problem
until
kubectl apply or your get ops operator starts
failing. And by that point, you're like, oh,
right. Well, what what have I got to
do to get this into my cluster? Right?
I wanna be able to deploy it. And
like the Kubescape comes at it with a
multitude of angles, but the most important one
being, can I scan this at pull request
time,
get something that tells me, hey, this isn't
actually gonna be admitted to the cluster because
of all these things? And then you can
fix them as part of the pull request
process. It makes things
a bit easier for new developers or people
that
aren't that familiar with this ecosystem and tool
chain completely. Now, of course, you should still
have validated mission controllers to block bad things
again in your cluster, But for the developer's
perspective, you're right. We have to make this
easier for them to learn these constraints and
controls and how to write better manifest.
Yeah. Completely.
And and beyond that, okay, I
what I
want to show you that I don't know
if you noticed, okay,
in this case and
but, okay, we are this is something, okay,
that we we also added
pretty recently, okay, that as you see that
I'm not just saying that you have an
issue within your deployment. Okay? And but, also,
I can point you to the the specific
line of of of of of problem. Okay?
So I can explain you that, okay.
And and and it connects you to to
to what you said about the pull request,
okay, and and improving your, you know, pull
pull requests and and and also,
obviously,
you know, action he's preparing. Okay? GitHub action
is is preparing that that we really see
this as part of a of a whole
process. Okay? So
to to catch the things and showing you,
okay, that that, you know, this is the
line of problem. Okay?
This is this is what you need to
check or this is not what you need
to say that, well, it's okay. But
but you need to, you know, create an
exception, and we'll talk about it in a
minute.
What is an exception
for us?
Awesome.
So Do you see a feature for this?
Like, I've now got I've got feature requests
for you. So
Awesome. Like, I want a little light bulb
in Versus Code to show up and actually
just fix it for me. Just remediation
like, hey, you should just set this to
false or hit there. You can modify your
service to be cluster IP and, like, be
able to guide people through how to make
this better.
Yeah. So
I know it's it looks like we have,
you know, premiitated these questions, but actually, you
know, we have some time.
And, yeah, this is this is something, you
know, we are we are working as right
now.
We are also to the which if you
know, we are again,
within the engineers,
okay, what we needed to do in order
to have these highlights, okay, is actually telling
you, okay, which, you know, part of the
YAML file, which, you know, which
fields
or fields are are related to this problem.
And what you're saying is not just, you
know, not just saying that, okay, the here
is the problem, but what the actual remediation
is
for this problem?
And and this is right now, it's we
are working on this today, more or less.
Awesome. And hopeful and hopefully, you know, I
don't know when we'll have the light bulb,
okay, because,
you know, we have to edit also to
the to the extension here, but but the
information will be there.
And, you know, this whole the Kubescape is,
you know, is is very, transparent. Okay? And
and, you know, the same output we are
we are generating here,
you know, can be taken, integrated into any
other tool. Okay? And
but I wanted to tell you that this
information is there, and also the fixed information
is what with the live op is going
to be there. So Awesome. Hopefully, really soon,
we will have Alright.
We got a couple more comments there. So
we have a child from John Luca. You
may have gone. Long time no see.
Mozz is in with another great question. Mozz
is curious if there are any plans for
Kubescape.
Now he's asked
if you're gonna create your own admission controller,
but I'm curious if you plan to do
that or whether provide policies for existing admission
controllers. Is that something that you've thought So,
yeah, we are we are thinking about it
really hard, okay, because really the
you know, we haven't talked about it yet,
but I don't know if you guys are
into it. Okay? I will be happy to
talk about the controls themselves, which are they
are written in in
in Rego,
and and
Kubescape was built on on Opa engine. Yeah.
Okay? So
which is we love it, and it's it's
a great tool.
And as of as you can see today,
we have a big set of of controls
and tests around it.
And we really think we are giving you
trying to understand, okay, what will take us
to to create an admission control. And, you
know, I I think that this is not
really the,
really, the question of really the technicality
of, you know, of implementing the admission control
API.
But, really, we are trying to create an
open source project which is, you know, which
is useful.
And, you know, having this full integration
with our with our Ragos and and rules
and controls
together,
you know, with Kubescape and this
and the the GitHub action and the and
the Versus Code. And together, okay, we have
an admission control. I think that we are
we're giving it a serious thought,
but we want to make it right. So
it's really important for us to, you know,
to make something that that is is is
usable and giving, you know, extra,
you know, extra value, okay, for for you
guys, for the whole community.
Yeah. That's that's really interesting to know that
it's using Opa and Regal because I guess
now, probably not too difficult to take some
of those policies and deploy them to be
consumed by gatekeeper right off the bat and
been able to then provide maybe someone in
the community is watching and thinking, well, I
use Kivernal.
Please go and start converting these to Kivernal
policies as well. Like, we have the artifact
hub and I'd love to see
all of these policies available to people regardless
of admission controllers. That would be awesome. Yeah.
That that would be great. Really great. And
and you can see that that the other
Qscape project in GitHub,
we have this regular library
project, okay, where where actually all the controls
you can see, okay, all the controls written
here in in
Rego
and understand how you can understand how they
work.
And now let's take this to
for example, the
privileged pod.
Alright. Whatever. Or the almost the IPC privileges.
So it these are simply, you know,
regular structures
and queries.
You know, it's it's different actually, it's it's
different from how a little bit how
Gatekeeper implemented things
because, you know, we really you know, you
can see all these
failed path and fixed path fixed path and
all the things, you know, we've just showed
you that to show how
the regulars are are not just, you know,
identifying the problem, but also telling you
what where the problem is and how to
fix it.
Therefore, they are these things that are Reggos
are a little bit different. Okay?
But still, you know, you can this open
source project and as well with the same
license,
and and this is what we're using in
Kubescape.
So anyone who's interested to, you know, to
do something with us
or without us, but using this, let's say,
is welcome.
Awesome.
Alright. We got away from Thomas Lav. I'll
pop that back off, and I'll let you
carry on with your demo. But this is
this is really cool. I like this. I
like what I'm seeing. Yeah. Yeah.
Thanks. And
so this is your really what you know,
Kubescape has
a few new directions.
Okay? And I'm also David, I hope you
agree, but I'm going to use this platform
also to ask for more contributions here to
to join our community. But I wanted to
show a a few interesting things. Okay? So
as I told you before,
you
know, Kubescape
is
started from scanning your API server. Okay? So
it connected the Kubernetes API,
talked to the API server,
you know, got all these, deployment
and secret and service objects, okay, and and
and, you know, told you what might wrong
with them.
Now
we understand that
security is more complex, and security is way
beyond, okay, only the API API server information.
Okay? All the things we can all the
objects we can get from the API server.
And
we have at least three directions, okay, we
started already to go into. Okay?
One is the host running the the the
the Kubernetes nodes. Okay? So we've created you
can see with in in in our GitHub,
we've created a project called
host scan host sensor,
which is actually a
high privileged daemon set,
which we're installing
during the scan on every Kubernetes node.
And it collects information
from,
the host,
which is hosting the actual Kubernetes node. Okay?
So we have access to the Linux kernel
and to, and to the environment which are
running to correct this node and not just
the API servers and the containers
from,
from inside.
So, for example, in this case,
what where it where it can help us.
Okay. So there there are different controls, okay,
which can leverage this information. Okay? So, for
example, I don't know if recall, I don't
remember the ex exact name of the CBE
vulnerability which was in the Kubelet,
like, you know, two two months ago or
something or three months ago in in December.
And in that case, okay,
we, as Kubescape,
we couldn't detect whether the actually, the hosts
are vulnerable because in order to detect that,
we also needed to understand what are the
kernel configurations,
on that host. And it's not enough to
read,
the Kubescape version,
which is available in node objects of
the API server.
And,
also,
beyond that, we've also,
looking into different, you know, other different things,
okay, in in the host.
For example, what is the version of, you
know, of your container runtime and and stuff
like that.
And and we collect this information, okay, and
we leverage this information to tell you more
about your security posture.
Now,
obviously, our host sensor itself
is is a high privileged,
container
within the cluster.
And,
therefore, what we are doing, we are installing
it during the run and rim right away,
after we collect the information, removing it. Okay?
So this is something this is a one
time thing in order to to, you know,
to to collect this information
and and and tell you what
what can be your potential security
problems. We are telling you about your host,
but but this is it. Okay? And then
we we we remove it right away.
Also,
we have gone to the direction that I'm
going to open our our
documentation.
We've also went into the the direction of
of learning more
of your cluster from the cloud provider.
Sorry.
So
so your cloud provider today,
you know, and and there were this is
why I think the question about whether Kubescape
can scan your your managed clusters
was a great question. Okay? Because on the
one hand, yeah, Kubescape can
scan your cluster. Okay? But on the other
hand, many information in the Kubernetes parts of
the Kubernetes control plane
are hidden from you where you're running a
managed Kubernetes cluster. Right? So when you are
you're running a GKE cluster on a EKS
cluster, you can you don't see actually the
API server pod.
Okay?
And, for example, if I'm returning here just
for a second for the test results, you
can see here that we have a a
a control called PSP enabled. Okay? Because in
general, we believe that post security policy is
an important security,
facility.
Although, I know this is deprecated,
and we are it's going to be swapped
out to something even better.
But but when we we can only test
whether PSPN is enabled using,
the Kube API when,
the API server is running as part of
the Kubernetes cluster, and we can
find the pod which is running the API
server and look into its configuration.
When it is a managed Kubernetes cluster,
for example, a EKS,
Okay? We don't have this information because we
don't see the API server plus because it's
something that AWS is taking taking care of.
So
in that case, okay, what we are we
are doing is, actually, we are connecting we
have enabled lately
in, cubescape to
be able to access,
the
API of the Cloud vendor,
detect which cluster we are running in, whether
it's an EKS cluster or GK cluster,
and,
and and, you know, talk to the API
of the cloud vendor
and and find out whether PSP is enabled
from the cloud vendor itself or whether ETCD
encryption is is, enabled,
also get the information from the cloud vendor,
because this information is not available through the
Kubescape API. So this is the second, you
know, the second angle, second data source, okay,
beyond the,
beyond the host sensor I told you.
And third, which is coming out, you know,
in this month,
is going to be vulnerability scan.
We are going to take inform vulnerability scan
information of your images in your cluster
and if they are available and
and use them as, you know, as an
additional information for writing controls, writing tests. For
I'm giving you an example, and I will
stop here because I need to drink something.
That
that for example, I I I give you
a for example, you have a cluster. Okay?
And and let's say that you're a very,
very
security conscious
DevOps engineer, and you are scanning your images
for security vulnerabilities.
Right?
But
what do you do with the results? Okay.
There are different you know, there are love
images with old, you know, old base images,
and you have you get every week, you
get a critical vulnerability.
And sometimes it doesn't really help, okay, because
it's, you know, it's more,
you know, it's more like a fog, okay,
because you have too many so many issues
that you cannot, you know, you cannot prioritize
by yourself. So what we're we decided to
do as a practical step from Kubescape is
to connect the vulnerability information with the information
we learn
from the Kube API. For example,
you have two
two deployments. Okay. One deployment
is is connected to a load balancer,
you know, in case, let's say, AWS, and
then it's an application
load balancer. And the second deployment is an
internal deployment, okay, which is not,
doesn't have access from the outside world. So
it's really clear that that in case that
the public facing,
deployment
has a critical vulnerability is way more,
way more critical issue than if an internal
application
has a critical vulnerability.
So us as security,
conscious,
people, if we want to start to fix
things, obviously, we have to start to fix
with the public facing workloads.
Okay? And this is what what we're going
to do at,
in the next step of Kubescape. We're going
connect we'll update the information together
with the the Kubernetes information,
and we'll try to give you
actionable items. Okay. Things which are you know,
we are we can say to you, like,
dude, this is something you have to solve
now. Well, this is more important than all
the others. And now I I I'm going
to sip a little soda.
Yep. You grab a drink. Alright. Audience, if
you have any questions I mean, we've covered
a lot so far about the different integration
points for Kubescape. Ben has also shared some
really cool things that seem to be coming
down the pipe, which I'm very excited about
as well. But if you have any questions
for anything that we haven't answered yet, feel
free to drop them into the comments
before we finish up, and we'll do our
best to answer them.
Alright. Feeling better, Ben?
Yeah. I'm way better. So what I want
to what I wanted to show you, okay,
is is actually, you know, the Kubescape
hosted the SaaS version, okay, the graphical version
of the results, okay, which can take to
to be here with you.
So
you can go to portal Arlo Cloud where
we are hosting, okay, our our Kubescape
UI.
You can sign up, you know, with your
favorite social log in
on this site,
and you can what you can do, you
can stream here your your results into this
in into this environment.
And, you know, I'm rerunning, you know,
are the same Kubescape scan
command here.
Just in this case, okay, if I added
my account ID,
so I'm uploading it to to my to
my bucket.
And,
you know, I can open right now the
the results here,
which should be
here within a minute.
And and I I can monitor my cluster,
you know, in a constant manner, okay, if
we have used your this mini cube,
which I've just set set up.
In this case, then I can see, okay,
all all the controls.
Okay.
You saw also in the CLI before. You
can see here, you know, the different frameworks
which we are running. You can see the
niche draft framework,
the NSA framework.
You can see here the
we have created a a framework of our
own, which we call Armor Best, which is
which contains, I think, the most
important
controls
you you should be running.
And, you know, what I like to do
here, okay, is really, you know, just looking
by severities. Okay? I I like to see,
okay, my issues, and I see that there
isn't there are no failed controls here. But,
for example, okay, I have here a high
severity issue with this privilege container.
And, again, this is the same results you
could see in the in the CLI.
And
and, you know, you can see here, actually,
the
the results themselves. And and with the same
in the same UI,
you can get here also the same information.
Okay. What is the the problem in the
YAML file? Okay. You need to you need
to solve here. Okay. So, again, really important,
okay, to to give,
you know, to to the Kubescape users, okay,
information
to, you know, to help solve the problems,
okay, they are having in their
environment.
And, you know, you can also there is
something, okay, I wanted to show here
that I think is really important. Okay? Because
if you remember,
I told you that
we we can see here two privileged containers.
Right? You can see an application,
okay, called recommendation service in the namespace called
Hipster.
Right? And
and you can see here also another called
Kubescape.
I think the you know,
although those who are viewing this stream, okay,
you already know heard about this.
And and it's in the Kubescape
KubeSystem
namespace.
And and again, you can see here that,
for example, in this case,
we are giving the users, okay,
a a light bulb, you've just asked,
that for that that we are recognizing
that this is usually a common failure. Okay?
This this test is usually faced because Kubescape
proxy
is
as of today, by design, it's a privileged
container. It needs to run as a privileged
container. But what you can do here, okay,
you can,
click here or here, okay, and create what
we call an exception. Okay. We can say
that, well,
I understand that this guy this workload have
failed.
But next time, I don't want to see
it as a failed workload. Okay? Because because
I understand I accept that this is this
is how it works. Okay? And I asked
this DevSecOps
or DevOps engineer
running this environment. I understand that this should
be like this. Okay? And I don't want
this to to affect my risk score. Okay?
Because I want to see my risk without
that.
And in this case, next time, okay, when
we are going to run Kubescape, okay, we'll
simply won't see, okay, this failure with the
Kubescape proxy.
And and the same goes okay for for
other so I can create an
exception for the whole namespace for a given
control or only for a given workload.
And and and this, you know through this,
you know, we are creating a workflow for
those who are refusing
clusters
and and want to, you know, want to
somewhat
accept
or or or, you know, create an exception
for for for specific workloads or namespaces.
Obviously, this is also supported in in within
within our our CLI, just a little bit
more messy to show it. So I hope
you forgive me that that I show this
way.
Up until now, everything is okay?
Yeah. Great.
Very cool. I'm curious about the ARMOR best.
Like, you know, this
security landscape in Kubernetes is is continually
evolving ecosystem.
There's new CVEs all the time and new
security practices. Like there's a certain level of
fatigue that a DevOps operator or SRE could
get from trying to constantly
fight all these different vulnerabilities and but but
also allowing their development and their application teams
to be Yeah. Productive and increasing their velocity.
Like, is ARMOR best
a kind of opinionated way to try and
minimize that fatigue?
Yeah. So
yes. First of all,
I I don't have good news, okay, for
all those who, you know, who have fatigue.
Okay?
Things won't be much better. Okay?
And yeah. And you're right. Okay. We are
trying to, you know, get some get our,
you know
not just, you know,
going after, you know, the NSA and mutual
recommendations,
but we are trying to create our own
own recommendation
package. Okay?
But but in in in for the static
part, okay, and and I I could totally
relate, you know, to your question, okay,
that
that we are trying to battle this this
overwhelming
stream of of vulnerabilities
and issues and information by
trying to build an open source project, okay,
which
which can give you enough context to actual
information
that you will be able to handle most
of the things automatically.
Okay? So
or at least we we are able to
I'm not saying to decide everything for you
as a as an SRE or DevOps engineer,
but but give you the most, you know,
you can have in a single
plain a pane of glass. Okay. So so
you have you can,
you know, can make as much less time
on this as, you know,
as you can. Okay. And not, you know,
not to relate not to stick too much
around these issues. Okay. Because
in in general, okay, this is really hard.
It's really, really hard. Okay? And and and
everyone understands that the
security, not just in Kubernetes.
Okay?
In in the modern world, security is hard
for everyone.
And and that but I do think that
Kubernetes is is a great way, okay, and
a great
project,
okay, which really security
gives the most it can to to security
minded people and and help them with that.
Yeah. I guess the another way to phrase
this would be if you want a secure
system, just turn it off. If that's not
an option,
then use
these tools, use the armor best as a
guidance and a compass. But,
I think what's really important and a paraphrasing
you still here, but like everybody's,
it's gonna depend company to company, right? Like
there is no gold star for what security
posture is within your organization. You you really
have to just understand
what's going on in the software and then
make those judgment calls yourself, I think is
Yeah. Is really important for people to understand.
Yeah. But but, again okay. So so,
you know, think about it just a little
bit for today. Okay. So today, like,
I think that we
had in the in the credit security community,
we, like, we had two security
issues in the past month. Okay? So,
again, I'm I'm not good by remembering, you
know, numbers. I know it's quite funny from
someone who's working in this industry,
But
but,
no, you had one big issue with Argo
CD. Okay? A directory travel travel so issue,
okay, which could be exploited by you know,
if you have Argo CD in your environment
and you are, you know, you're using some
malicious
chart, okay, or or, okay, to pull your
your stuff from,
then, you know, someone can
steal data from your cluster.
And the second was a container escape vulnerability
in the Linux kernel,
which was, you know, reported more than a
month ago.
And in both cases okay. So these were
great cases, I think, to understand, okay, that
that how complex these things are because
okay. First of if you don't have Argo
CD in your your Kubernetes cluster, okay,
then great. Okay.
You are not most likely, you are not
affected by this issue. Okay?
But most more you know, ArgoCD is is
a great tool, and and it's going into
more and more clusters. So many, many people
were thinking, well,
I do have a vulnerable ArgoCD
version. What do I do now? So the
next step is simply to start, on the
one hand, update ArgoCD.
On the other hand,
you know, you have to check whether you've
been as affected.
Have you been what are the list of
of help charts or or GitHub Git
repositories you've been pulling from.
And and there use it starts to be
really hard, okay, because you have to go
understand.
If you're managing one cluster,
you may be able to do even two,
like, three, four, five, and and
and, you know, tens or or even hundreds
of of developers,
this can be start to become very, very,
very hard.
The same goes for for, you know, for
the Linux kernel
container escape issue. Okay? Because
it was even even harder because,
you know, everyone who uses Kubernetes most likely
is running on Linux kernels. So Linux kernels
are, you know, even more common than than
ArgoCity.
So you cannot say that, well, I don't
have Linux kernel, therefore, I'm fine.
And
you start to have, you know, update your
kernel, which is a pain it's a real
pain. Okay? So it's it's really, really hard,
Even you're when you're yet running managed clusters.
And and
you start to to have a look at,
okay, how what is the attack angle? Okay?
How an attacker can get
to this?
And there, the privileged containers comes into the,
know, into the play, okay, because privileged containers
were more vulnerable to this.
I can actually tell you that even if
you're looking into the container landscape,
okay, actually,
other container orchestrators,
okay, which we are right now not pulling
by by their name,
were less vulnerable, okay, to this container escape
than actually
the the Kubernetes
because Kubernetes was disabling seccomp by default
and and others weren't. So and this this
had an effect. So it's really, really hard
and really, really hard to understand, you know,
these all these small things.
And therefore, I think that going forward,
the only way we can ham handle these
things and not be overwhelmed
is to connect more and more information and,
you know, somehow, you know,
replicate, you know, the the security,
you know, all those people who understand security
really well and understand Kubernetes really well and
and let them code
this knowledge
into some regular rule or something like that
and enable others simply choose just to take
this information and get whether they have problems
or get an answer, yes or no, whether
they have problems or not.
That's my take.
Awesome. Thank you for sharing that. That was
great.
So
another thing, okay, I wanted to show you
okay. Again,
live demo. I'm I'm sorry. So we have
we have we have our own
image scanning
facility, okay, you can install in your cluster.
So I'm going to
for that, what we are doing is we
are installing
Kubescape and other Kubescape components
into your cluster with Helm.
And this will do two things. One is
will enable you to scan your images in
your cluster
every day.
And the second thing it it does, it
also scans your
your Kube API just as you saw before
in a constant manner. So in other words,
if you like Kubescape and want to work
with it
in
a permanent manner. Okay? And and
wait a second. Do I have Helm here?
What a mess.
What a mess. Okay. Nice. Nice. Yeah. We
we yeah. We got to this
at the end.
Wow. Wow. No. Yeah.
On arsenal next helm is helm dash bin.
Helm is actually something else.
Oh, well. A dash bin. Sorry. Dash dash
bin. Sorry.
Yeah. It may be an AUR. Do you
have
an AUR package manager?
AUR.
Oh, I I mentioned Like, yeah. Or something.
Pretty pretty pretty new machine. Oh.
And haven't been able to to start to
set up things here. So, yeah, this is
the but let let me get back, okay,
because we have enough data. Okay? So let's
for example, let's say we have we have
installed, okay, this Helm chart, okay,
in in our cluster. Okay? And you will
have daily scans,
okay, of the of your in this case,
for example, in this G K cluster when
you can see the progress of your cluster
day by day.
And and not just that, but we're we're
starting to have image vulnerability information
from your cluster. So you're we are installing
our our vulnerability scanner inside your system. We
are scanning every every workload looking for for
image vulnerabilities issues. For example, I want to
see only critical
problems,
for example, with RCEs.
And I can see that, for example, in
the the same recommendation service we've seen before
which had
which which was a privileged component.
Okay. I can see here that it also
have, you know, a CV with critical vulnerabilities,
although it's not an RCE.
Having said, it is a problem.
So, again, this is something you're will relatively
new. Okay? And and and we are, you
know, we are still working on it and
working it more interesting.
But in order to for you to understand
that we are adding more and more and
more information input to to this system to
have a more interesting, you know, results and
more helpful results
for you. Another thing is is our RBAC
visualizer which was, you know, started as a
pet project for one of us,
here.
And we said to ourselves, well, you know,
guys,
RBAC in Kubernetes,
which is, you know, really today a a
a a a
part of of of, you know, of Kubernetes
security because every modern cluster uses
RBAC authorization
for it. It it is it is great,
but it's a mess. It's really hard to
handle. Okay? So so what we've decided is
simply, you know, create a a a,
you know, a visualization
for for what you have for your, you
know, for, in your cluster, what you see
in your Rawkode. So in this case, what
you can see here,
you can see here
a service account, okay, called Kubesystem
sorry, Kubesystem default
service account of the Kubesystem namespace,
which is bound to the
cluster admin role,
okay, which is obviously, it's a pretty high
privileged role, okay, in in in Kubernetes, which
is actually the highest privileged role. And you
can see that that also there is another
group connected to the same role,
okay, which is called system masters group.
And they have, like, access to every resource.
You can see here the asterisk.
It can execute every
work on every resource,
okay,
in this cluster. So it we can see
how, actually, how the map, the mapping of
of the what we call the administrator is
happening. Okay? But but on their hand, okay,
we can start, start to, you know, your
lookup more interesting thing. Okay. We can we
can so that who has access to Kubernetes
secrets?
So we can who can do GET on
on secrets. Okay?
And
asking who can perform. So you're getting a
graph, okay, of all,
the roles and cluster roles in in the
environment who have access to resource
secrets.
Okay?
You can see here that on the one
hand, where is our
basic,
admin role. I forgot. I don't see it
for now, but, for example,
we have different roles.
Let's
try to layout by by type. Okay. We
can see here that in the middle, we
can see here all the roles,
and we can see all the subjects, okay,
bound to those roles
here.
K. We can see here that we have
a a user
called Kubescape controller manager because, obviously, a built
in
user in in in Minikube.
And it has it is bound to to
to this role called Kubescape controller manager, which
has update, get, delete, and create
authorization
over Kubernetes secrets.
Okay?
And
I don't remember if I have here something
more interesting, but for let's take
let's take another,
query.
K? For example, we've made some pre built
queries. For example, who can exec in into
pods. Okay? Exec exec integration into pods. Okay.
It's, again, it's an important thing, okay, to
control.
And we can see here, okay, that that
the only one who can do it is
the, cluster admin. So we are more or
less fine. Okay? But, for example, if we've
would if there was some kind of a
project which which introduces its own authorizations
into the system,
okay,
we see here
many interesting things because,
for example, I've we've been talking with a
lot of users,
and they said that they started to play
around, okay, with this,
with this,
Rawkode visualizer.
And
and it turned out that they found out
the different RPAK and authorizations were were there
in in their system,
which they didn't know, know about before.
So,
so it's really, really important, okay, so also
to know what are the kind of authorizations
you are having in your system. And I
RBAC Visualizer is a great great way to
to start to understand,
what do you have, in your environment.
Yeah. I'm going to stop here also for
taking questions.
That is the coolest and most important thing
I've seen in oil, the rbag visualizer. Like,
see when we're talking about exploring Kubernetes clusters.
Like everything in the cluster is primarily two
dimensional and kubectl get is fine.
RBAC on other hand, because we've got names
based objects, cluster based objects, we've the aggregation
layer for doing, you know, grouping certain permissions.
You can't well, at least it's very difficult
to understand who has access to what they
can do. Now, of course, you can use
Kubescape control all through AMI and get
a scope thing from an individual user, but
being able to look at that across an
entire cluster, this visualizer is just amazing. Like,
whoever built this is is just is now
my new hero. This is amazing. Yeah. Yeah.
I'm going to I I think that's yeah.
It it it it's simply a great
it's a wonder it was a wonderful idea.
Okay. And and and I the credit needs
to go also to,
Youssef and and the team from the Ankara
University who helped us to build it because
they did an awesome job
on this. Okay. They're coming from a fraction
from the graph
graph theory
direction,
and I think that they did made a
really, really great
tool here.
And I just switched switched to another cluster
because my
mini cube was pretty, you know, pretty boring.
But
but for example, okay, in this case, okay,
you can see that in
let's try who can.
Let's try to pre make query. Okay. Who
can exit into pods. So we found so
many interesting things, for example, which Google
installs. Okay. In in this case, okay, you
can see that not just cluster admin has
access to
to executing into pods, but also there is
a g k common webhooks
user
with the cluster role g k common webhooks
cluster role, which also have
access to executing
into into pods. And, yeah,
this is this
is great to understand how things are working
around.
Yeah. For sure.
What what I like about Kubescape here, I
I don't know if this is a phrase
or not at this Kubernetes security industry. Kubescape
seems like it's a full spectrum tool. Like,
you know, we've looked at mass configuration. We've
looked at image scanning. There's the RBAC visualizer,
we have the integration with all these security
frameworks.
And it's really tackling the security thing from
all the different angles that people have to
be concerned about with their Kubernetes customers. And
I think that's really important. That single tool
can deliver,
like like you said in the the market
message and and and the GitHub repository,
a single pane of glass for Kubernetes.
Yeah.
And and, yeah, you again, so I I
you know, I'm not trying to say that
we've solved all the problems. Okay? We are
far from them.
And we are also you know, we are
we are trying to make some something really,
you know,
something really new and and very, very useful.
Okay?
And, therefore, if, you know, if anyone who's
here, okay, and
wants, you know, be involved in the project,
okay, we are welcoming you know, we have
a great Discord channel.
And, also, you know, our GitHub is is
very, you know,
busy.
So, we really invite anyone who want to
join us in the journey, okay, and creating
this great, open source tool,
to join our ranks.
Alright.
Should I move back over to just video
mode? Are we done with the demonstration for
today? Yeah. We are more than done.
Yeah. Sorry. Awesome. Sweet. I'll I'll make sure
to include links to the Discord and the
GitHub repository in the show notes. You know,
we do like to encourage people. People are
always watching these videos and asking how can
they be involved. So it's it's great that
Kubescape is is actively looking for people to
come and, I guess, provide suggestions, documentation,
and code and and just talk. Right? The
Discord server is there for people to share
their stories about security.
Completely.
Yeah. This is very important.
Really important. I think that the feedback is
sometimes
I know it's, you know, it's a little
bit funny to hear, but sometimes the good
feedback can even go further than than the
actual code itself.
It it can be so important to understand,
okay, the how the people are using and
at Kubescape and what are their problems and
how they want to
how we can solve another problem they haven't,
you know, they have which is related or
or or how did we did things wrong.
Okay? Because sometimes we might, you know, we
might did something which wasn't you know, we
didn't it's right, and we need to fix
it.
So any input is where is good input.
Alright. Last question for you. I forgot to
ask during the demo because the RBAC visual
issues the RBAC visualization thing just struck me
as awesome. But has anything that you've shown
us
paid for? Is is this all free?
So what everything I've shown you is free.
Okay?
Even our sales version is free. Okay? We
have a limitation of
of notes,
which can be seen on the ARM website,
okay, that we have a limitation
of notes, okay, obviously, because we this can
be a lot of data
to handle for us.
But but, actually, you know, it's
we we Kubescape is is free, and the
CLI tool is free. It's going to be
it's still going to be free forever. And,
hopefully, you know, fingers crossed that we've submitted
cubescape for CNCF sandboxing.
And on the March
8,
the TOC will sit on it, and, hopefully,
we'll accept cubescape as a CNCF project. So
we'll become a a CNCF project hopefully very
soon.
Well, that would be great. You have my
plus one nonbinding vote for that. Alright,
Ben. Awesome. Thank you for joining us today.
I hope everyone has liked what the scene
from Kubescape
from integrating into GitHub actions to run on
the command line to a very cool web
UI
and the amazing RBAC visualization.
So go check it out, join the Discord,
and be active in the GitHub.
Any last words, man?
No. Thank you, guys. It was great for
being here.
Yeah. Again, thanks. Thank you. Well, have an
awesome day. Thank you for sharing that demo
with us, and I'll speak to you again
soon. Thank you very much. Thank you. Bye.